ja was macht dich zum Personal Trainer
von Franc potente weil sie hat erzählt
du da hat das hat da hat die Chemie
gestimmt was muss da passieren damit
zwischen dir und dem Star den du
betreust die Chemie stimm
was passieren muss damit die Chemie
stimmt ist folgendes erstens mal ist es
so dass ich sehr intim mit dem Klienten
arbeite ob es nun Sänger Schauspieler
oder sonst welche Künstler sind das
heißt man muss sich erstmal sympathisch
sein ganz wichtig weil man ja sehr eng
zusammenarbeitet und weil der Situation
entstehen
du weißt selber wenn jemand zu dick ist
ist unehm darüber zu sprechen Problem zu
ich muss anfassen ich bin sehr dicht an
dem Künstler weil W mit prominenten
arbeitet kann man nicht überall einfach
hingeen und trainieren sondern gibt
Situationen im Hotelzimmer Backstage
oder sonst irgendwas es ist immer man
muss sehr speziell sein und man muss
glaube ich 100% für den Künstler
Menschen oder Klienten da sein immer und
jeder Zeit bereit das heißt du lernst im
wahrsten Sinne des Wortes die
Schwachstellen kennen ja äh ich lerne
wohl die Schwachstellen kennen muss
lernen mit den Schwachstellen umzugehen
und muss auch
wissen wie ich mit dem Künstler
umzugehen habe wenn Künstler auf dem
Projekt arbeitet auf eine Tournee auf
ein Film oder sonst irgendwas ist immer
hochspannunger ist immer voldldampf und
ich bin schon dafür da dass die Leute
ihre körperlichen Ziele erreichen das
heißt also übers Kochen übers massieren
übers relaxen mit
hotstone also in allen Situationen muss
ich da sein muss manchmal auch ein
bisschen den Stress rausnehmen und bin
eigentlich auch so rund um Betreuung für
den Künstler es ist ein sehr harter Job
und ein total schöner
Job dieses Buch ähm kick ass das
alternative Workout wer das befolgt wird
der so wie deine Kunden in
Anführungszeichen also der Kick er
befolgt wirk nicht unbedingt wie meine
Kunden unser Ziel war es also mein Ziel
auch speziell gerade mit Franc zu
arbeiten war es eigentlich zu sagen ey
einifert nicht falschen Zielen hinterher
sondern schaut euch an und bewegt euch
einfach nicht irgend aussehen wie der
und der Star oder fit sein wie sonst
irgendjemand son einfach mit euch selbst
zufrieden sein und ein Workout zu
schaffen was wirklich machbar ist ohne
ein teures Gerät zu kaufen sondern
einfach das Buch nehmen aufschlagen und
sofort loszulegen das war eigentlich
unser Ziel und man kann auch das Buch
nehmen und damit üben richtig
gesehen ja wir haben super Designer
dabeiab der sagt komm lass uns das Buch
so machen das muss es Buch ist ein
Arbeitsmaterial bevor ich eine teure
Handel kaufe kaufe ich mir das Buch
schlag's auf und leg los aber man kann
es auch für Übungen selber in die Hand
nehmen also ich ich weiß du we du meinst
Fran so schön beschrieben Butterfly z.B
ist ein Gewicht aber dafür ist es Buch
also das ist für Anfänger zu leicht da
sollte man schon lieber so ein fetten
Brockhaus oder SAS okay dann doch zum
Brockhaus okay aber wieso ist es zu dem
Buchprojekt bekommen zwischen dir und
Franc warum hat das nicht ein anderas da
gemacht haben die anderen keine Zeit
oder
das mit mir und Franc ist eine spezielle
Symbiose weil wir uns sehr gut verstehen
auch und für mich war es wichtig also
ich habe das Buch schon jahrelang im
Kopf weil ich dachte ich will endlich
mal den Leuten zeigen wie einfach ist es
einfach mit mit sich selber zufrieden
sein ein bisschen fitter zu werden und
Franka ist ein total cooler Typ finde
ich die ist die lebt ihr Leben und ist
aber auf dem Punkt genau fit und ich
habe gesagt lass uns jetzt zusammen
machen sie hatten kurz nachgedacht hat
gesagt okay machen wir übrigens Franka
hat do sofort vom ersten Moment unser
Buch muss kick ass heißen es gab nie ein
andere geren Vorschlag und Franc ist ein
Typ auch mit dem also das ist eine
Vertrauenssache und es hat einfach diese
Zusammenarbeit macht einfach total Spaß
und das heißt arbeiten Sie mit ihr denn
besonders intensiv
ich arbeite eigentlich mit jedem
künstlerintensiv also das ist so dass
über die 20 Jahre ja mein mein meine
künstlerkartei nicht größer wird weil
einfach ich bin zu eng an den Künstlern
und mit Franc ist es schon sehr intensiv
weil wir auch ziemlich also z.B bei born
gibt's sehr harte Ziele die von den
Filmproduktionen vorgeschrieben sind und
da muss man schon sehr nah am Künstler
sein und das ist natürlich die die Sache
wie verkaufe ich mich dass der Künstler
nicht merkt wie hart wir eigentlich
trainieren und über bei Franka ist eben
so eine Symbiose das funktioniert
eigentlich und und gerade speziell auch
die Übung die wir weil z.B das kommt
noch dazu frank ist ein apromi das heißt
gerade mit ihr kann ich nirgendswo
hingehen wir mussten eigentlich immer so
Hotel und da und da trainieren da sind
Übungen entstanden die einfach dur ich
dachte Mensch musüssen man jeden Mann
jeder Mann mal zugänglich machen das
Besondere an den Übungen ist auch man
kann die überall eben machen man nimmt
ein Stuhl man nimmt irgendwas ich sage
immer das Buch ist machbar wir wir haben
gesagt wir wir es gibt zwei Teile im
Buch einmal für zum zum Einsteigen Übung
so eine Mischung aus Übung für den
ganzen Körper und einmal so ein kleinen
Hardcore Zirkel dieser Hardcore Zirkel
ist übrigens wirklich Daus entstanden
weil ich Franka noch fordern musste und
habe einfach mal so ein Zirkeltraining a
aufgebaut so wie wie man es in 80er
Jahren gemacht hat und so erst hat so
lange zne gekriegt habe ich aber gesehen
dass sie das Spaß gemacht und dachte ich
Mensch das können wir ins Buch bringen
weil wenn ihr erstmal ein bisschen
blutdelekt hat am Sport der wird mit dem
Zirkel Spaß haben aber jemand der jetzt
dieses Buch nimmt der hat ja der muss
nicht oder andersrum gefragt wenn du
sagst wenn jemand dieses Buch nimmt der
muss nicht das Ziel haben ich muss die
und die Körperkontur haben und 10 kg
weniger wiegen sondern er sollte ein
anderes Ziel haben welches das Buch äh
es soll jemanden helfen eben nicht äh
einem Superstar nachzueifern oder sich
in ein Körper reinzusteigern den er
nicht erreichen kann worst cas ist ich
beschreib es mal kurz eine Frau sieht
irgendwo ein illustrierten eine tolle
Figur und fängt an zu hungern wird
passieren zuerst geht das Gesicht
langsam zurück dann wird der busenfacher
bevor sich überhaupt was am Po bewegt
dann ist das Gesicht verhähend weenn man
das Ziel nicht erreicht man wird mit
sich unzufrieden und ist gnatig ich
finde viel schöner zu sagen Mensch lass
mich doch vielleicht nur 2 3 kg abnehmen
mich aber fitter fühlen und mich so zu
trainieren dass meine Ausstrahlung schön
ich mit mir zufrieden ist doch viel
schöner also für mich ist nicht zählt
nicht jemand dünn oder in falschen
Körper zu trainieren sondern ihn schön
attraktiv werden zu lassen weil sich
wohl fühlt das ist eigentlich das
Wichtigste das heißt wenn man dieses
Buch befolgt kann es sein dass man immer
noch 10 kg oder 5 kg zu viel wiegt aber
man hat eine bessere Ausstrahlung ja es
ist nicht mehr zu viel weil es woanders
sitzt vielleicht oder es kann sein dass
man noch zu viel 5 kg zu viel wiegt aber
wer sagt denn dass es 5 kg zu viel sind
wenn ich mich selber mit 5 kg mehr wohl
fühle dann finde ich es das Ziel viel
mehr erreicht als wenn ich 20 kg abnehme
und einfach unzufrieden verhagert und
unattraktiv
bin aber bei ihr du sagst da gibt's so
harte Vorbedingung von der Produktion
was steht denn in so ein Vertrag drin
muss so und so viel wiegen muss den und
den Bizeps Umfang haben oder mussen die
Gewichte stemmen oder liegt das an den
Szenen die man dann spielen muss es ist
sehr sehr verschieden also man muss
unterscheiden zwischen Film Fernsehen
und und Musikbranche die
Verträge geben schon gewisse Vorgaben
also wie man sich ob man ein bisschen
schlanker sein muss ein bisschen härter
gerade bei actionfil ist es so dass das
Körper gefragt ist natürlich Fleisch
gefragt ist also es kommt drauf an Star
über sag mal über eine te singenden Star
über einee zu bringen ist schwierig dass
er am Ende der der Tournee genauso viel
Power und Ausstellung auf der Bühne hat
dass er gesund und fit ist oder eben bei
Franc z.B geben vor sie muss eben 8 Kil
schlanker sein und da muss man da eben
auch wirklich hart hinarbeiten aber
gibt's ja noch exaktere Vorgaben als 8
Kil schlanker
eben was weiß ich den und den
Brustumfang oder oder
oder ja das hat ja vom Shape gesprochen
der entwickelt sagt ihr dann der Shape
soll so aussehen oder sagt das schon die
Produktion das kommt auf an mit
welchenem künst man zusammenarbeitet es
kann sein dass die Produktion das sagt D
ist es natürlich also wenn die
Produktion so eine harten Vorgaben den
Körper so zu formen gibt ist natürlich
eine ganz extreme sind ganz viel Druck
hinter gerade mit internationalen
Produktion die dann eben sagen was auf
kann bei Männern kann z.B gesendet sieht
man an bestimmten Actionstars dass die
praktisch zum Film hin topfit sind
dicken Bizeps haben ges shapt sind und
drei Monate später einfach mal wieder 5
kg mehr wiegen also sind schon sehr hohe
Anforderung die wir in Deutschland aber
noch nicht so extrem haben ich Ken es
von Peter Alexander der sah das ist 20
Jahre her der sah der hatte jedes Jahr
eine Show war der rank und schlank ein
Mann ein Bild von einem Mann aber in den
Jahren dazwischen in den Monaten
dazwischen sah der aus wie jeder andere
Rentner in Deutschland auch aus sieh man
die die da sieht man die
Professionalität der Künstler die sagen
eigentlich bin ich liebe ich das
Lotterleben und ich wenn ich nicht auf
Tour bin oder zum Film bin bin ich total
entspannt lass es mir gut gehen was auch
wichtig ist weil man mental abspannen
muss zwischen den einzelnen Aufgaben
aber dann auf dem Punkt deswegen macht
es auch so viel Spaß mit Künstlern zu
arbeiten weil die einfach die
Professionalität haben auf dem Punkt
dann auch so auszusehen dann kann man so
richtig quälen und mit allen Waffen
schießen die man so aufbringen
muss aber bei Franka ist es anders die
macht das durchgehend Franc trainiert
durchgehend weil sieind sehr also sag
mal so Franc ist nicht der optimale
Leistungssportler aber Franc hat do
immer ein Gewissen ehgeiz und bei ihr
ist so wie so ein wie so ein TuneUp das
heißt al der Film kommt näher der
Training wird härter professionell wenn
der Training wenn der Film weg ist dann
wird's mal trainiert oder mal nicht aber
also sie hat immer eine gewisse
regelmäßige Unregelmäßigkeit sagen wir
mal so was sagt denn DJ Soos wenn du
jetzt einfach nach Berlin abdampst das
sind Absprachen die man einfach mal
machen muss die für die ja wichtig sind
und das muss man vorher erklären also
ich habe bestimmte also bei mir sind so
bestimmte Künstler haben Flats das heißt
wenn dann Film beginnt oder so bin ich
Standby bei ihn jetzt ist es so dass ich
dann kurz mal sage ich muss mal kurz weg
und dann ist er zwar traurig aber wir
haben auch ein sehr großes Ziel vor ich
bewunder den Mann sehr und da wird's da
wird das ist eine Arbeit die ich liebe
wenn ich jemanden komplett umformen kann
und wenn sich jemand wie wir zum Anfang
schon gesagt haben komplett auf mich
einlässt also wenn ich bin total stolz
darauf wenn sich ein Künstler komplett
in meine Hände begibt ist dann ist bin
ich erstmal richtig gefordert gut das
kann ja auch nicht so gut aussehen wie
wenn ich an unseren ehemaligen
Außenminister jfischer denke der sah so
ein bisschen verhärmt aus als er so
wahnsinnig abgenommen ja wobei es ich
glaube bei dem ging es auch nicht um
eine optische Veränderung sondern es war
ja wirklich so eine mentale so eine
knüppeltour zu sagen ich will jetzt den
Marathon laufen und so hat man gespalten
mein ich finde die Leistung super gut
aber das aussehen kann auch sch und V
das ist wirklich ungesund was man da
treibt weil es ist Marathon sollte man
nicht unterschätzen und das muss man
wirklich eigentlich sollte Marathon
laufen ist eigentlich eine
Lebensphilosophie dieses on off bei bei
solchen extremen Sachen ist schon
gefährlich auf jeden Fall kann ich dich
denn auch buchen und wenn ja für was
grundsätzlich kann mich jeder buchen ist
natürlich sehr schwer wenn du mit vielen
Künstlern arbeitest ich bin fast das
ganze Jahr lang auf Tour nehmen mir war
das Recht raus auch mit in
anführungsstichchen ich Beton es immer
wieder mit normalen Leuten zu arbeiten
und wenn man ganz großes Glück hat komme
ich auch vorbei und gebe gute ratstü
trainiere mit Leuten auch kostenlos nein
z.B gibt's bestimmte Festivals wo
Künstler für ein gewul den Zweck
auftreten da gehe ich auch hin dann
gibt's so das gibt die körperwerkstatt
Schellberg da gibt's so zwei Stunden
Gespräche mit mir wie man trainieren
kann wie man auf dem Punkt genau
trainieren kann wie man essen kann wie
man kochen kann wie man relaxen kann
sowas mache ich sehr gerne aber
Privatleben hast du nicht ich habe ein
sehr gutes Privatleben ein Glück ich bin
seit 13 Jahren verheiratet habe drei
Kinder und diese blöde Floskel zu sagen
hinter jedem Mann steckt eine starke
Frau ist bei mir ganz ganz wichtig weil
man wird in dem Business auch sehr also
man ist sehr unter Stress und probiert
den Künstler alles abzunehmen was man
kann und da braucht man wirklich eine
gute Hinterhalt und meine Familie hat
mich mal mehr und mal weniger